the house of Heroes is about to get a
whole lot bigger in the aftermath of the
November 12th launch of its brand new
streaming service Disney Plus the Walt
Disney Company has kept its momentum
going by announcing future plans for its
various film branches including its
vehement subsidiary Marvel Studios the
company confirmed on Friday November
15th release dates for five yet untitled
marvel movies scheduled to open between
October 2022 and November 2023 The
Hollywood Reporter had the complete list
of release dates October 7th 2022
February 17th 2023 May 5th 2023 July 28
2023 and November 3rd 2023 this plan
pins Marvel as rolling out four films in
2022 to untitled Marvel projects slated
for February 18 and July 29th black
panther 2 which is coming on May 6 2022
and the newly announced mystery movie
scheduled for an October 7th 2022 debut
it sets the studio up to release four
movies in 2023 as well
that outline matches up with what Walt
Disney Studios chief creative officer
and co-chairman alan horne previously
said about content plans for marvel
studios or noted in an october 2019
interview with thr that marvel studios
chief content officer kevin feige
would be making three or four Marvel
movies per year four years after the
inception of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe with 2008 iron men and after
seeing how well director Joss Whedon's
the Avengers performed both critically
and commercially Disney increased
production of Marvel movies to a
consistent - per year by 2017 the Mouse
House had put Marvel on a three movies
per year scheduled that year saw the
launches of guardians of the galaxy vol
2 in May
spider-man homecoming in July and Thor
Ragnarok in November in 2018 Marvel
released Black Panther on February 16th
Avengers infinity war on April 27 an
ant-man in the wasp on July 6 this year
saw the debuts of Captain Marvel in
march avengers endgame in April and
spider-man far from home in July
see that wasn't so hard stupid what's
interesting about Marvel's new plans is
that the studio has seemingly learned
from its past decisions playing even
smarter this time around by spreading
its upcoming films out across the
calendar year the successes of Black
Panther Avengers infinity war and
Avengers endgame spider-man homecoming
and Thor Ragnarok may have influenced
the studio to stick with release dates
around those times moving forward it may
also be seasonally motivated scheduling
movies for February May July and October
November ensures that Marvel has one big
theatrical event in winter spring summer
and fall or a decision made to avoid
over saturating the market with Marvel
content and potentially causing
superhero fatigue with all that set of
mystery still lingers what Marvel movies
are going to fill those newly announced
release dates plus the ones previously
confirmed for 2022 being the stealthy
studio it is Marvel likely won't reveal
what's coming in 2022 and 2023 for quite
a while however that doesn't mean there
isn't enough information out there to do
a bit of speculating the only Marvel
film confirmed to arrive in 2022 is
black panther 2 which will open on may
6th of that year that leaves three other
movies to slot into the February 18th
July 29th and October 7th windows during
Marvel's buzzie panel at this year's San
Diego comic-con Kevin Feige sneakily
confirmed that Captain Marvel -
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 and
another Fantastic Four film were
underway and would be arriving at some
point in the future those flicks may be
a part of phase 4 but they weren't
included on the 2020 and 2021 Marvel
movie slate which accounts for Black
Widow and May 20 2010 November 2020
thankee and The Legend of the ten rings
in February 2021 Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness and may 2021
spider-man 3 in July 2021 and Thor love
and thunder on November 5th 2021 now
it's entirely possible that the Captain
Marvel sequel James Gunn's third
guardians of the galaxy movie in a
Fantastic Four reboot are the three
no films lined up for release in 2022
alongside Black Panther to the first two
projects are in development as of this
writing and with Disney's acquisition of
Fox in March 2019 the studio will
undoubtedly want to fold its newly
bought characters into the fabric of the
MCU on the other hand it's also
plausible that Peyton reads ant-man 3 or
the mashaallah a lead led blade reboot
could be the fourth movie Marvel has
slated for 2022 like Captain Marvel 2
and guardians of the galaxy vol 3 Ant
Man 3 and the new blade movie are
officially in the works while nothing
official regarding a Fantastic Four
flick has been announced just yet
additionally Captain Marvel will
probably need a third flick after the
sequel as will Black Panther and Doctor
Strange Herc blade may even require a
second and third follow-up flick
depending on how well the reboot is
received these are all possible projects
Marvel is cooking up and planning to get
out into cinemas in 2023 at the end of
the day though no one can say with
complete certainty what new MCU
installments are coming throughout 2022
and 2023 Marvel is clearly hoping to
continue dominating the box office and
remaining at the epicenter of pop
culture consciousness and these five new
mystery movies are just another boon in
a long list for the studio check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite MCU movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the belt so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]